[Musique]
c'est un rituel qui fascine toujours
autant les enfants
la caravane du tour de france accueilli
à bras ouverts
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est la première fois que je fais ça
avec la caravane
c'est la première fois aussi que mon
passé dans ma ville à dreux c'est majeur
nier aujourd'hui est ce que tout le
monde est heureux et c'est bien et à
ramasser des choses haribo pour la
plupart de ces jeunes a mené par le
secours populaire d'heure et d'eure et
loir c'est leur toute première fois ils
ont même droit à leur carré viiip en
bord de route
rien que pour une journée au bout de
vacances et l'occasion de mettre en
selle c'est oublier du sport qui ne
connaissent pas tous le cyclisme
derrière l'ébullition de la grande
boucle il y à l'idée de partage au
programme des ateliers et un parcours en
bmx
pour certains c'est même la toute
première fois qu'ils enfourche un vélo
pour cacher un cliché qui colle encore
aux roues du cyclisme un ancien coureur
venu en dédicace est bon pour les
coureurs et puis quelque part de savoir
que que tout c'est quoi on était enfants
un monde au nez et des rêves
qu'ils perdent pas espoir que ce soit
dans le vélo dans leur vie personnelle
professionnelle ou dans un autre sport
la petite reine a trouvé ces princes des
graines de sportifs encore sous
l'adrénaline d'un tour vécu à cent à
l'heure et qui pourrait qui sait
susciter un jour des vocations
[Musique]